frau bundeskanzlerin meine damen und
herren wir freuen uns die deutsche
bundeskanzlerin frau dr angela merkel
zum arbeitsbesuch in moskau zu empfangen
wir haben heute inhaltsreicher und
hilfreiche gespräche geführt und dabei
haben wir über wichtige fragen der
bilateralen beziehungen im politischen
bereich im wirtschaftlichen bereich im
kulturellen humanitären bereich
gesprochen und natürlich haben wir uns
eingehend mit der dringenden
internationalen fragen auseinandersetzen
möchte unterstreichen die russland ist
bestrebt die zusammenarbeit mit der
gleichberechtigung des gegenseitigen
vorurteile und der berücksichtigung der
center der interessen des jeweils
anderen zu gestalten
die bundesrepublik gehört zu den
wichtigsten außenhandelspartner
russlands und rangiert auf platz zwei
gemessen am handelt nach china im januar
und oktober vergangenen jahres ist der
bilaterale handel bei der marke 83 43,8
milliarden us dollar gelegen
die deutschen investitionen belaufen
sich auf 20 milliarden dollar die
russischen kapitalanlagen in deutschland
auf 9 milliarden us-dollar russland und
deutschland realisieren einige große
energie politische projekte wir schätzen
die verantwortungsbewusste position der
deutschen bundesregierung für das
bekannte projekten aus trier 2 bei den
gesprächen haben wir auch über die
fortsetzung der franzis russischen gases
durch die ukraine gesprochen
wir haben unterstrichen dass die
vereinbarungen vom 31 dezember wichtig
sind denen zufolge daran sie zu
lieferungen in den nächsten fünf jahren
durch die ukraine geliefert gesichert
sind
diese
vereinbarungen sind ausgewogen und
gegenseitig vor deiner tür russland und
der ukraine und natürlich entsprechen
sie den interessen der russischen
verbraucher die europäischen verbraucher
der russischen eliteliga
bei der diskussion über eine
internationale und regionale
tagesordnung haben wir uns vor allem mit
libyen beschäftigte wo es groß angelegte
kampfhandlungen gibt für die
terroristischen aktivitäten zu erleben
und die bewirtschaftung der soziale
bereich zum leidwesen aller verfallen
das alles unterläuft sicherheit und
stabilität nicht nur in der region
selbst sondern hatte auch negative
projektionen auf europa damit meine
echte illegale immigration schmuggel
hand die verbreitung von waffen und der
bewaffneten konfrontation zwischen der
libyschen nationalen armee von
machohafter und der regierung der
nationalen einheit seiner interseite
braucht einen waffenstillstand müssen
maßnahmen ergreifen mit denen der
politische prozess wieder aufgenommen
werden kann damit die spaltung innerhalb
des landes überwunden werden kann und
gemeinsamer staatlicher institutionen
entstehen gerade auf diese ziele ist die
gemeinsame erklärung abgestellt die ich
zusammen mit dem türkischen präsidenten
abgegeben habe wo wir rivalisierender
parteien zu stoppende ab mitternacht
nächsten jahres ich habe frau
bundeskanzlerin eingehend über unsere
arbeit in istanbul informiert alles
zeitgerecht betrachten wir auch die
deutsche initiative in berlin eine
internationale libyen konferenz
stattfinden zu lassen damit die berliner
konferenz gewichtige ergebnisse zeitigt
muss man dafür sorgen dass die staaten
daran teilnehmen die ein wirkliches
interesse an der unterstützung für die
libysche regierung haben und hauptsache
die beschlüsse müssen vorab mit
libyschen parteien abgestimmt sein
eine rolle dabei zu spielen hat der
sonderbeauftragte des generalsekretärs
der vereinten nationen zu libyien herr
salami bei den gesprächen haben wir
natürlich auch über die lage in der
syrischen arabischen republik gesprochen
ich habe frau
bundeskanzlerin selbstverständlicher
auch über die bilanzen meiner jüngsten
reise nach damaskus informiert das
gleiche gilt auch für meine gespräche
mit präsident assad man kann mir
zuversicht verstellen dass die lager in
diesem land zu sicht stabilisierte
syrien kommt langsam aber sicher zum
friedlichen leben zurück die syrischen
staatlichen strukturen werden wieder
aufgebaut deutschland und russland eine
gemeinsame meinung der zufolge der
konflikt in syrien abschließend nur mit
politischen mitteln zu lösen ist im
sinne der resolution 22 54 das un
sicherheitsrates
hauptsache dass der syrische volk die
möglichkeit hat frei und eigenständig
über die eigene zukunft über die zukunft
des eigenen landes zu entscheiden
gerade dieser ansatz liegt die
erschaffung des verfassungsausschusses
zum ko runde
diese dieser ausschuss hat schon zwei
sitzungen gern stattfinden lassen und
hat eine redaktionelle kommission
gebildet die mit der arbeit und der
verfassungsmäßigen grundlagen des
syrischen staates betraut ist russland
will zusammen mit der türkei und mit dem
iran im rahmen des astana format nach
kräften diesen ausschuss unterstützen
wir haben auch über die in der post
konflikte am wiederaufbau in syrien
gesprochen über die verbesserung der
humanitären lage und über die sichere
rückkehr von flüchtlingen alle
verantwortungsbewussten internationalen
akteure müssen ihre bemühungen zusammen
und legen damit die damit die syrische
regierung stellen und die syrer im
weitesten sinne des wortes dabei
unterstützt werden die infrastruktur
wieder aufzubauen wasser und
stromversorgung wieder aufzubauen
schulen und krankenhäuser jegliche hilfe
muss aber nach rücksprache mit legitime
regierung geleistet werden und sich auf
alle betroffenen gebiete erstrecken
ohne dass irgendwelche vorbedingungen
und politisierung
betrieben wird natürlich wussten wir
auch über eine weitere frage sprechen
die sehr wichtig ist nicht nur für diese
region sondern für die ganze welt
das ist der erhalt von gcp nachdem die
usa sich geweigert haben dieser
vereinbarung zur folgen haben die
iranischen partner erklärt sie führten
ihre freiwilligen verpflichtung aus dem
gpk aussetzen ich möchte unterstreichen
es geht um freiwillige verpflichtungen
aber sie unterstreichen ihre
bereitschaft zurück zur vollständigen
erfüllung indessen klar die uns zukommen
russland und deutschland entschieden
dafür dass jessica weiter umgesetzt wird
die iraner können sich auf die
verpflichtung der europäischen länder
verlassen
die versprochen haben dann unabhängigen
finanz mechanismus für den handel mit
iran zu entwickeln dieser mechanismus
hoffentlich denn er soll seine arbeit
aufnehmen
die haben eingehend auch über die lösung
der in der ukrainischen krise gesprochen
wir sind uns einig dass der metzger
vereinbarungen eine alternativlose
grundlage für eine normalisierung der
lage sind aus der ukraine darstellt und
es ist wichtig dass die aufgaben die wir
beim jüngsten nummer die gipfel
formuliert haben auch realisiert werden
wir hoffen sehr dass die ukrainische
seite politische vereinbarungen
realisiert die verlängerung des unter
status gesetzt das ist schon ein guter
schritt in die richtige richtung aber
dieses gesetz muss dauerhaft angelegt
sondern so wie das in der metzger
vereinbarung festgeschrieben ist der
sonderstatus das muss in der ukrainische
verfassung damit aufgenommen werden was
sind die metzger vereinbarungen
festgeschrieben dass wir verstehen die
schwierigkeiten des in politischen
prozesses in der ukraine aber nach alle
interessierten parteien eine
abschließende lösung wünschen dann muss
man den weg der umsetzung der metzger
vereinbarungen abschließend möchte ich
noch einmal deutlich machen bei den
gesprächen mit frau bundeskanzlerin
konnten wir unser eingehend und
konstruktiv mit vielen wichtigen fragen
auseinandersetzen die sich sowohl auf
die deutsch-russischen beziehungen
beziehen als auch auf die stabilität und
sicherheit im nahen osten und irgend der
ganzen welt ich möchte frau
bundeskanzlerin von herzen für die
produktive zusammenarbeit heute sagen
vielen dank
ja ich möchte mich auch hier nach moskau
und die gelegenheit zu einem umfassenden
gespräch und umfangreichen gespräch
sowohl zu den fragen der bilateralen
zusammenarbeit als auch zu den
internationalen fragen
in der tat können wir sagen dass trotz
einiger schwierigkeiten zum beispiel
noch bestehenden sanktionen im zusammen
mit der ukraine wir intensive
wirtschaftliche beziehungen habe aber
auch in den bereich wissenschaft
universitäten gerade in der jetzigen
zeit zwischen deutschland und russland
sehr intensiv zusammenarbeiten wollen
und ich glaube gerade auch den menschen
bürgerinnen und bürger unserer beiden
länder in kontakt sind kann das nur
produktiv sein
wir haben auch über das projekt nord
stream natürlich gesprochen ich glaube
dass dieses projekt auch durch die neue
europäische rechtssetzung legitimiert
ist und dafür ist deshalb zu ende
bringen sollten
unbeschadet dessen hat es
glücklicherweise und erfreulicherweise
einen guten gas abschluss für die
nächsten fünf jahre für den transit
durch die ukraine gegeben wir haben ja
auch verfolgt das jetzt das projekt noch
schrieben eingeweiht wurde und ich darf
hier den sagen die wir die sagen wir
kommen in eine einseitige abhängigkeit
dass deutschland und auch die anderen
europäischen länder die von nord stream
profitieren es gibt ja im übrigen heute
schon nord stream 1 das ist jetzt keine
ganz große neuheit mit note 2
dass die alle auch eine interesse an
einer diversifizierung ihrer gas
lieferungen haben und das auch weiter
betreiben werden aber ich glaube das ist
ein wichtiges projekt wir haben dann
über die frage der internationalen
konflikte gesprochen
zuerst möchte ich auch libyen erwähnen
ich glaube es war ein gutes treffen
zwischen dem türkischen präsidenten
erdogan und dem russen wladimir putin in
istanbul bei dem jetzt an einem
waffenstillstand gearbeitet wird der ein
erster schritt sein kann hin auf das was
im berliner prozess zwischen den fünf
vetomächten des sicherheitsrates und
fünf weiteren interessierten ländern
ausgearbeitet wurde auf der hohen
beamtenebene und wir waren uns einig
dass wir jetzt sehr bald zu einer
konferenz nach berlin einladen können um
unter der führung der vereinten nationen
ich will das ausdrücklich sagen der
generalsekretär gitarrist der
beauftragte herr salami sind hier in der
hauptverantwortung einen prozess
auszusetzen der zum schluss den
libyschen parteien eine möglichkeit gibt
ein souveränes friedliches land zu haben
das heißt es geht um nichteinmischung um
souveränität und deshalb sollten die
parteien die in libyen jetzt im
augenblick in einer militärischen
auseinandersetzung sind stellvertretend
willich nennen herrn starts und herrn
haft da auch natürlich engstens
beteiligt seien bei der lösung dieser
fragen wir hoffen dass die russischen
bemühungen ein russisch türkischen
bemühungen einen erfolg bringen und
werden dann aber sehr zeitnah auch
einladen
für eine berliner konferenz wir haben
über libyen gesprochen und über syrien
gesprochen
desweiteren und hier hat ja auch das
gespräch präsident erdogan präsident
putin wichtige ergebnisse gebracht ich
freue mich dass jetzt ist in der letzten
nacht gelungen ist zumindest zwei wo man
nicht ihre übergänge in richtung zu
wieder offen zu halten denn es gibt dort
eine große not der menschen im blick auf
die flucht aus stimmten zonen und
deshalb freue ich mich auch dass über
möglichkeiten eines waffenstillstandes
dort gesprochen wurde
denn gleichermaßen wie in libyen gibt es
ja keine militärischen lösung sein es
gibt letztlich nur verhandlungslösungen
und auch darauf setzen wir und deshalb
setzen wir uns einerseits ein dass wir
noch einen weiteren humanitären übergang
bekommen in richtung nordosten syriens
da gibt es auch bereitschaft gespräche
weiterzuführen und zum zweiten dass wir
vor allen dingen den prozess vor dem un
beauftragten pedersen unterstützen der
den verfassungskonvent leitet denn eine
politische lösung muss da sein damit die
gegebenheiten für ein syrien da sind in
das auch menschen wieder zurückkehren
können die aus syrien geflohen sind und
das sind ja leider sehr viele
insbesondere viele syrer sind heute in
der türkei und die türkei trägt hier
eine wirklich große verantwortung
um diesem ergebnis des verfassungs
prozesses auch die nutzer unterstützen
werden wir auch weiter mit russland mit
der türkei und mit frankreich sehr sehr
eng zusammenarbeiten
wir haben natürlich über die situation
im iran gesprochen und sind uns einig
dass wir alles daran setzen sollten
das abkommen
das shakespeare zu erhalten deutschlands
überzeugung ist dass der iran keine
atomwaffen bekommen sollte und auch
keine haben sollte und deshalb werden
wir alle diplomatischen mittel auch
weiter einsetzen um hier
dieses abkommen was sicherlich nicht
vollständig ist nicht vollkommen ist
aber was immerhin ein abkommen ist und
verpflichtungen aller seiten beinhaltet
dass wir dieses sozusagen am leben
erhalten
ich möchte in dem zusammenhang noch
feststellen dass jahr 176 menschen
gestorben sind bei dem abschuss eines
flugzeugs 176 unschuldige menschen im
iran
es ist heute vom iran bekannt gegeben
worden dass dies ein großer fehler war
und es ist gut dass die verantwortlichen
damit bekannt sind und ich glaube dass
jetzt auch alles unternommen werden muss
um mit den betroffenen nationen aus
denen die bürgerinnen und bürgern kamen
lösungen zu finden dass vor allen dingen
umfassend aufgeklärt wird und zum
anderen eben auch darüber gesprochen
wird was die folgen daraus sind es ist
jedenfalls wichtig eine schonungslose
aufklärung aber dazu ist heute ein
wichtiger schritt passiert trotzdem
bleibt es ein dramatisches ereignis
deshalb werden wir auch im blick auf den
irak alles daran setzen die bekämpfung
des terrorismus des islamistischen
terrorismus weiter zu ermöglichen und
die spannungen in dieser region so weit
wie möglich abzubauen
wir haben natürlich über das normal lief
format gesprochen
wir hatten hier in paris ein doch würde
ich sagen teilweise erfolgreiches
treffen es war jedem klar dass nicht
alle probleme lösen können aber das ist
zum jahresende einen gefangenenaustausch
gegeben hat dass man sich um eine
waffenruhe bemüht die leider nicht
vollkommen ist das ist richtig und wir
werden jetzt die arbeiten fortsetzen um
beim nächsten gipfel dann auch weitere
fortschritte in der reihenfolge der
minsker vereinbarung zu übernehmen wir
waren uns einig wir haben diese
grundlage auf der müssen wir arbeiten
bei allen schwierigkeiten dass es
langwierig aber wir haben den willen
dazu
insgesamt war es also ein umfassendes
gespräch und ein wichtiger
meinungsaustausch und ich hoffe dass
daraus auch weitere folge ereignisse
erwachsenen in denen russland und
deutschland aber auch zusammen mit
vielen anderen ländern wir einen beitrag
dazu leisten können das diplomatische
lösung eine chance haben und dass wir
auch die arbeit der vereinten nationen
in all diesen konflikten unterstützen
können die kollegen das wird
vorgeschlagen jeweils zwei fragen zu
stellen wir beginnen mit deutschen
medien ja von deutscher seite zuerst die
frage von thilko gries vom
deutschlandfunk
vielen dank ja ich bin korrespondent des
deutschlandfunks in moskau ich würde
gerne mit ihnen über libyen sprechen
der türkische präsident hat vor wenigen
tagen gesagt in libyen hielten sich 2000
sogenannte wagner seltener auf also
mitglieder des russischen privaten
militärunternehmen soir frage an sie
herr präsident über die menschen über
den studien bestätigen sie diese zahl
2000 wagner seltener jedoch sollten sie
sich nicht bestätigen
wie viele söldner halten sich russische
söldner halten so wagner söldner halten
sich in libyen auf sollte es dort
russische bürger geben so vertrete nicht
die interessen des russischen staates
und sie bekommen auch kein geld vom
russischen staat in der konfliktzone
gibt es generell viele verschiedene
artiges ordner nach unseren angaben gibt
es viele söldner die aus der at
lektionen syriens in die konfliktzone in
libyen verlegt worden
das ist ein sehr gefährlicher prozess
zusammen mit einer art umgang habe ich
gestern auch das besprochen wir hoffen
dass nach unserer vereinbarung und wir
gehen davon aus dass diese
vereinbarungen auch durch die
konfliktparteien in syrien gefüllt
werden also wir gehen davon aus dass die
kampfhandlungen eingestellt werden und
somit auch
man damit aufhören zusätzliche soll nach
libyen insbesondere aus syrien zu
verlegen vielen dank die nächste frage
kommt von der nachrichtenagentur tass
catharina kock guten tag
nachrichtenagentur interfax mit die
frage für alle staats und
regierungschefs ich muss eine frage zum
ostring zwar stellen werden wir unter
den bedingungen der sanktionen selbst
moslem bauern können und wenn ja in
welchen fristen eine frage für
bundeskanzlerin will berlin irgendwer
russland dabei unterstützen nord stream
zu bauen oder diese frage auf die
tagesordnung washington setzten den
bezug auf die sanktionen wenigstens
deshalb weil der gastransit durch die
ukraine gelöst worden ist in der tat
werden wir auch auf eigene faust dieses
projekt zum abschluss bringen ohne dass
ausländische partner damit eingezogen
werden
die frage der fristende ist die einzige
frage die da mitte aufgeworfen wird der
abschluss der bauarbeiten wird natürlich
um einige monate verzögert sein aber ich
hoffe das wird bis ende des laufenden
jahres oder im ersten quartal nächsten
jahres geheimer die arbeiten werden dann
abgeschlossen sein und partnern kann der
betrieb genommen werden also bei aller
politischen implikationen und diese
politischen diskussionen finden ja über
stadt ist es zuallererst mal ja ein
wirtschaftliches projekt das hier
vertreten wird und deshalb halten wir
dieses projekt für richtig die daran
beteiligten unternehmen haben sich ja
auch immer wieder dafür ausgesprochen
und
ich glaube nach der diskussion dass es
eben möglich ist muss den 2 trotz dieser
sanktionen doch zu vollenden der
russische präsident hat den zeitrahmen
genannt es gibt eine gewisse verzögerung
aber dass man ist wirklich vollenden
kann und ich will an der stelle noch
einmal sagen bei aller politischen
kontroverse mit den vereinigten staaten
von amerika halten wir die
exterritorialen sanktionen nicht für
richtig und deshalb unterstützen wir
dieses projekt auch weiter so wie vorher
was aber im kern natürlich ein
wirtschaftliches projekt ist charlotte
meierhof rtl charlotte meinung ist mein
name rtl aktuell und n tv ich habe eine
frage an unsere kanzlerin
wir haben eingangs gehörte sie viele
scharfe fragen so war die formulierung
der übersetzung zu diskutieren haben wir
haben aber jetzt auch gehört dass es
viel einigkeit gibt zwischen deutschland
und russland zwischen der eu und
russland
manchmal ja auch entgegen der haltung
der usa können wir uns in zukunft darauf
einstellen dass wir kooperationen sehen
werden zwischen russland und der eu
unter umständen dann in einigen fragen
auch gegen die usa
ich habe mir eben ein beispiel genannt
bei dem es auch unterschiedliche
meinungen mit den vereinigten staaten
von amerika gibt die unser verbündeter
sind mit denen wir in vielen fragen
zusammenarbeiten und wir definieren aus
deutscher sicht aber auch aus
europäischer sicht natürlich wie immer
in der aussenpolitik erstmal unsere
interessen und russland definiert seine
interessen und wir tun gut daran zu
gucken wo haben wir gemeinsamkeiten in
diesen interessen und die haben wir
gefunden bei allen schwierigkeiten in
den mint prozess da gibt es viele
gemeinsamkeiten in den bilateralen
beziehungen gibt es auch
meinungsunterschiede die themen über die
wir heute gesprochen haben vom tsv wo
wir im grundsatz der gleichen meinung
sind immer gibt es auch unterschiedliche
blickwinkel aber ich glaube ein solcher
besuch hat einfach den vorteil dass man
miteinander spricht wie ich es am anfang
schon gesagt habe und nicht
übereinander dann sich auch versucht die
argumente des anderen zu verstehen alles
eines ist nur klar ob es egal ist auch
das lieblings ob es für ihn ist es wird
militärisch kann man eine ganze weile
etwas tun aber eine lösung wird es zum
schluss nur politisch geben und ich
glaube wir haben heute in konstruktiver
weise darüber gesprochen wie wir solche
politischen lösungen finden können
da gibt es gegensätzliche auffassungen
aber glücklicherweise gibt es auch
überlappungen indem man gemeinsame
lösung freunde dann sehen kann und auf
der basis auch arbeiten können
dank und letzte frage maria kritisch
weil du bist du ja noch ist die
elektrische ich habe vage einsehen und
meine stadt
ich möchte das thema von libyen
fortsetzen werde ich nicht frau
bundeskanzlerin erlernte besteht eine
große marina und wir lieben uns und
welche und da sich jetzt die frage an
herrn orten angesichts der reaktionen
der libyschen parteien aber das
memorandum lästigen vereinbarungen die
sie im rahmen von weiteren regionen wird
in der türkei erreicht habe dann gibt es
eine chance dass die waffen entsteht und
eine zweite weitere frage ob zum nahen
osten insgesamt in den letzten tagen gut
sind im roby gasser im zentrum der
weltnachrichten ist ins gesicht der
verschärfung der beziehungen zwischen
dem iran den ordensmann pessimistische
einschätzungen und es gab wollte dass
die welt am rande des krieges ist aus
ihrer sicht welche auswege gibt es um
die situation im nahen osten insgesamt
zu erschaffen
insgesamt anbelangt so hoffe ich das
es lag eine groß angelegte militärische
konflikte geben ihr das wählen krieg da
ist dass wir selbst system kann
intensiver krieg aber sind kompanien
menschen werden getötet das ist eine
tatsache wünschten uns sehr große
kampagnen vermeiden zu können wenn sich
besseren würde dann wäre das grob nicht
nur für den nahen osten sondern für die
ganze welt wir verstehen der hier
konsequenzen das haben würde
das werde daran zu 49 wellen führen
nicht nur noch europas und dann in
andere regionen es wäre eine humanitäre
katastrophe
es wäre eine religiöse und
wirtschaftliche katastrophe beste würde
dazu führen dass ein großer schaden für
die weltwirtschaft und welt energie
angerichtet wird
wir hoffen dass wir durch gemeinsame
anstrengungen dazu treffen wir uns auch
heute mit frau bundeskanzlerin haben wir
uns hier in moskau getroffen um unsere
gemeinsame schritte zu besprechen und
diese negative szenarien zu vermeiden
denn in syrischen konflikt anbelangte
möglichen hoffe ich sehr dass den
kommenden stunden in fünf stunden die
wir das sind herrn erdogan appelliert
haben sie und pflegezeiten libyen die
kampfhandlungen einstellen werden dann
möchten wir weitere konsultationen mit
ihnen durchführen und in meiner
erklärung habe ich schon gesagt wir
unterstützen die initiative der
bundeskanzlerin um unter der ägide der
uno in berlin die konferenz
durchzuführen einige sachen bedürfen
noch der vorarbeit aber es wäre in
butter schriften sie richtig hinter gut
errichten um die negativen erscheinungen
zu vermeiden sie ich am anfang erwähnt
habe und das würde den weg bereiten für
schritt
froh dass es heute gelungen ist auch die
von der russischen seite die ersten bei
allen vorbereitungsarbeiten in berlin
auch mitgearbeitet hat die aussage zu
erhalten dass wir sehr bald eine solche
berliner konferenz durchführen sollten
wir werden jetzt mit den anderen
potenziellen teilnehmern natürlich
sprechen müssen und wir hoffen dass die
bemühungen der russischen seite gerade
auch im blick auf einen waffenstillstand
mit den entsprechenden analytischen
parteien auch zu einem erfolg führen
wir haben vereinbart uns sehr intensiv
und eng auszutauschen in diesem
zusammenhang aber natürlich auch mit der
türkischen seite
auch innerhalb der europäischen union
die außenminister sind hier in einem
sehr engen kontakt innerhalb europas
aber vor allen dingen auch die
vereinigten arabischen emirate und
ägypten sind hier in diesem zusammenhang
von großer bedeutung und wir wissen dass
das ganze nur unter der ägide der
vereinten nationen stattfinden kann und
dass wir quasi die arbeit des
generalsekretärs und des
sonderbeauftragten salameh unterstützen
mit unseren bemühungen eine solche
berliner konferenz kann nur der auftakt
sein für einen längeren prozess und zum
schluss muss ganz sicher sein dass es
die libyschen interessen im vordergrund
stehen es geht um dass du die zukunft
libyens
das muss nur verhindert werden dass zu
viele länder von außen sozusagen
versuchen einfluss zu nehmen und dabei
die typischen interessen vollkommen in
den hintergrund geraten und ganz
besonders hervorheben möchte ich in dem
zusammenhang noch die rolle der
afrikanischen union und der
afrikanischen länder
dann wäre und wenn wir uns einmal die
nachbarschaft von libyen anfahren dann
leiden heute vor allen dingen die länder
südlich von libyen also die saarländer
die g5 sei länder ganz besonders unter
terroristischen entwicklungen und gerade
diese terroristischen entwicklungen
werden wir nur eindämmen können wir auch
in libyen wieder ein friedliches
miteinander haben und eine wirkliche
staatlichkeit von libyen und das ist das
ziel an dem wir arbeiten und ich hoffe
dass wir da jetzt in den nächsten tagen
und wochen wirklich vorn kommen und
schluss
vielen dank